[Music]
britain's prince andrew faces a
potential lawsuit in the u.s over
allegations that he sexually abused a 17
year old girl in the early 2000s these
allegations stem from his long-standing
friendship with gelane maxwell a
socialite who is closely connected to
convicted sex offender jeffrey epstein
the lawsuit comes at a complicated time
for the british monarchy and if a trial
goes forward it could coincide with a
queen celebration of 70 years on the
throne
the prince could settle and so this
trial might not go ahead at all but if
it does there is the risk that andrew
will have to be cross-examined by
lawyers and may reveal embarrassing
details about the alleged events that
took place in the early 2000s
the real question here is if if there is
a financial settlement who's actually
pay buckingham palace will have to
navigate that very very very carefully
because if it is seen to be the british
taxpayer who's picking up any of the
bill for this there could be a huge
public backlash
the allegations brought against prince
andrew have been swirling for years a
woman named virginia gefray alleges in a
lawsuit that she was forced to have sex
with prince andrew when she was 17.
she claims she was trafficked by epstein
and maxwell that the prince was aware of
that fact and that he abused her in
london new york and on epstein's private
island
juffrey filed the lawsuit against prince
andrew last year he has denied all
allegations
in 2019 prince andrew did an interview
with the bbc during which he said he was
friends with jeffrey epstein he also
said that he and epstein weren't very
close and that he had never met jufree
i have no recollection of ever meeting
this lady
none whatsoever you don't remember
meeting her and he was presented this
this photo which is now well known of
him with his arm around mr frey and he
said he had no recollection of that
photo being taken and since then he's
not said anything really publicly
jeffrey epstein died in jail while
awaiting trial on sex trafficking
charges in 2019 and in december 2021
guillen maxwell was found guilty on
criminal counts of sex trafficking if it
goes ahead prince andrew's trial on the
civil suit could take place in the fall
one of the big issues here is that a
trial could be reputationally damaging
for for prince andrew for the monarchy
but also for prince andrew's direct
family and that means that there is a
big big incentive here for him to just
pay to make this go away and that's the
that's the most likely outcome
lawyers say but the big question is what
mr frey will ask for in return because
it might not just be money it may also
be some form of apology
cut off from his royal duties prince
andrew has lost much of his income and
there's uncertainty over how he might
pay for a potentially expensive
settlement
according to royal biographers prince
andrew still has a pension from the navy
and owns a chalet in switzerland that is
up for sale buckingham palace didn't
immediately respond to a request for
comment about his assets the financial
risk he faces that he is unemployed he
is someone who has no job and so
therefore will presumably be relying on
his mother
or any wealth he accumulated before to
kind of pay his way from now on
this is all threatening the monarchy's
image at a delicate time
after it became clear in early 2022 that
the lawsuit could proceed to trial
buckingham palace stripped the prince of
his military titles and patronages and
announced he would no longer use the
title his royal highness
he is still a prince he is still the
duke of york but he is no longer his
royal highness and he no longer has any
role to play in the sort of ceremonial
duties of monarchy prince andrew isn't
the only royal this has happened to most
recently prince harry and his wife
meghan markle agreed not to use their
royal highness titles when they quit the
royal fam
harry was also stripped of his military
affiliations
as the royal family works to defuse
reputational damage from these recent
incidents it's also being faced with the
challenge of preparing for the eventual
passing of queen elizabeth she turns 96
this year and has already stepped back
slightly from public duties her son
charles and grandson prince william have
as a result been stepping up more
prince andrew now is effectively
holed up on his mother's estate in
windsor
plotting his defense as a private
citizen
in a way he is now a sort of prince
without a role he's in a sort of
semi-exile
and it really depends how this court
case plays out i mean some question that
even if he did manage to clear his name
or settle with virginia dufresne he
would
always be tainted by association given
his friendship with maxwell and epstein
and that means that it'll be very hard
for him to ever be rehabilitated